hello Rob here with an overview of grand
theft auto online skon 10th creator that
came out alongside a patch last month if
you haven't been impressed with GTA
lately you should be happy to hear that
the content creator definitely brings
more to the table by letting anyone
create and easily share their own
original jobs currently still in beta
you only get to create two basic job
types but it's safe to say that Rockstar
will have more down the road for now
strap in baby let's check it out load up
creator and choose whether you want to
make a deathmatch or race job I'll be
going over the deathmatch creator but
both types start off the same in detail
options where you'll have to create a
catchy title and enticing description
keep in mind for the photo option you'll
want to come back and retake that photo
once your creation is completed to
better show off what your job is about
moving on
choose job details like how many players
time limits score limit and whether you
want players to start off with their own
weapons or restrict them to your menu
you got cooking all this is fairly basic
but where your creativity really lies is
in the placement options start with a
catchy trigger location and sweet Lobby
photo and move on to player spawn points
picking team spawn points is fairly easy
but it gets a little tricky when you
have to pick an additional two spawn
points for each player when they die
meaning a 16 player match requires 32
spawn points which is a little
time-consuming if you're trying to give
everyone a fighting chance upon spawning
but hey who feels people in GTA online
play fair oh that's right no one so make
things interesting
throw in a juggernaut type spawn with
armored minigun and plenty of cover or
make someone a little less fortunate by
placing him out in the open surrounded
by gas tanks or how about a spawn on top
of a skyscraper with a bike directed
towards a ramp with arrows for an
entrance that screams fat-ass top the
rest of your map off with up to 50
weapons 25 vehicles and 50 prop elements
to make it your own
once you're done test it out with some
AI morons and it feels good enough
publish that baby to Rockstar social
club head over to your trigger spot host
and invite for all to enjoy
Oh
great well good thing you can always
modify and update your jobs whenever you
want the race creator is simpler where
waypoints and obstacles are your main
tools for creativity truly though the
great part about GTA creator is how it
further pushes the online community just
head to social club online and check out
countless creations see something you
like book market load up GT online and
it's right there in your map they're not
always perfect but find the right one
and you can make some solid cash get
enough people to like your job and you
can get Rockstar verified for some major
promotion all in all GTA crater does a
great job at better tying the community
into online play and the best part is
knowing there's a lot more to come
thanks for watching and be sure to tune
in to GameSpot for all of your gaming
news